So let's look at a few other
refinements we can make.
For starters, I think it's
pretty lame that we've
gone through all this
work to sign the user in,
and all we say is,
"Welcome, player!"
We know our user signed in.
We should talk to
him or her by name.
So let's do that.
Now what I'm going
to do here is go
into my IntroView controller.
And where we say refresh
interface based on sign in,
instead of saying
"Welcome, player,"
we're going to get that
information from the Google
Play Games service.
So we're going to
do here is we're
going to say self dot
sign-in label dot text equals
in a string, string
width format,
welcome object to
be named later.
And if you've either started
browsing through our reference
documentation or are just
kind of fooling around
with code hitting,
maybe you've notice
that through the GPG
manager shared instance,
we can get this thing called
the application model.
And this starts to contain
some interesting information
about the application.
One thing it contains
is this property
called Player, which has
another property-- I think
the only thing associated with
it right now-- called Local
Player.
That has a name.
So let's see what
happens when we run this.
Oh, we get, "Welcome, (null)."
That's not right.
So what's going on here?
Well, what happens is when you
sign into Google Play Games,
the Google Play Games service
will go out onto the network
and start fetching
information that it
thinks you're going to
need, like information
about the player, definitions
for all your achievements,
the player's progress
towards completing
those achievements and so on.
However, since we're trying
to say hello to the player
immediately after
sign in complete,
the service hasn't
had enough time yet
to go out and get
all that information,
or at least confirm that
the cache information it has
is still up to date.
So how do we fix this?
Well, one way might
be to add a timer,
so that two seconds later
we say hello to the player.
But there's a more
elegant way of doing it
that the service
provides for us.
So instead of setting
the text right away,
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to call the GPG
Manager, shared instance,
and I'm going to access
the application model.
And within the
application model,
I'm going to call this
method load data for key
with a completion handler.
Now the key here is-- and
this is just a constant
that we define, GPG, model,
and you can see it down here,
local player key.
And for our completion handler,
let's indent that a bit.
Now we can look and say,
well, if there was no error,
set self dot sign-in
label dot text, equals,
in a string, string width
format, welcome object.
And then we can
call GPG manager,
shared instance,
application model,
dot player dot local
player dot name.
Whew.
Now this time when we
run the application,
we get back a
personalized message
that says, "Welcome"
with my name.
By the way, there's
also another method
called reload data for key.
Now this method works almost
the same as load data for key.
I believe the difference
is that reload data for key
tells the service,
I want you to ignore
any cached data you have.
Go out on the net
and actually grab
any new information,
whereas load data for he
says, if you have cached
information, it's OK to use it.
So I think if we run this, you
might see a slightly longer
delay in between when the
Sign Out button appears
and the welcome talk
message appears.
And I believe that's
because I'm making
an extra, or a
forced network call,
that I didn't
necessarily have to make.
So we're going to switch this
back to load data for key.
Finally, I'm going to
show you one other problem
that we might want to fix.
Now, I've got a pretty
good internet connection.
As it turns out,
Google's got internet.
Go figure.
But watch what happens
when we run this.
You're going to see for a brief
moment that the G+ Sign In
button is still there.
It takes a moment
for the service
to sign me in and make the
Sign In button go away.
And certainly when I'm
out in the real world
on 3G network or something,
that delay could be much longer.
And you don't want
your user repeatedly
clicking that Sign In button
thinking that, for some reason,
they're just not
getting signed in.
So what we want to do
is, we get to that moment
where we're trying
silent authentication,
we want to let the
user know, hey.
We're trying to sign you
in in the background.
Please be patient for a minute.
And we can do that by
looking at the value that
gets returned by
trySilentAuthentication.
Now this actually
returns a Boolean.
And this Boolean is
yes if the system
has determined that it is
going to try and silently
authenticate the user.
It says, looks like there's
an old OAuth token here.
I'm going to try and
sign the user in.
So we can take
advantage of that.
First thing we're going to do
is create a load property here.
Not atomic, BOOL, that
is trying silent sign in.
And then down here,
I'm going to say
self dot trying
silent sign in is
equal to the value
that gets returned.
And remember, this gets
returned immediately
by the trySilentAuthentication
method.
And then we can go back up
to our refresh interface
based on sign in method.
And we're going to go up
here and say, self dot sign
in button dot enabled equals
not self trying silent sign in.
So if we get to this point,
the user is not signed in yet,
but the system is
attempting to sign them in.
You will see the Sign
In button visible,
but it will not be enabled.
Similarly, if the user
is not signed in yet
and silent authentication has
failed, or the system says,
I don't think this person's
logged in before or just
wasn't able to silently
sign the user in,
the Sign In button will be
visible and it will be enabled.
There's one other
thing I forgot to do,
which is here under
finish with auth.
We get to this point
once the attempt
to silently sign the
user in is finished,
so we can say self dot trying
silent sign in is equal to no.
All right, so now
let's run this.
And you should see that that
Sign In button was visible
but disabled for that brief
moment in between signing in
and when the Sign
Out button appeared.
Now I'm going to sign out.
And it looks like
the Sign In button
is there and is
once again enabled.
I'm going to click it.
I'm going to say Accept.
Go back into the game.
And there we go.
We're signed in.
We have a nice Sign Out button
that, again, we could probably
hide in a menu
somewhere, and the game
is addressing me by name.
I feel like we're
friends already.
So at this point we're pretty
much done with the section
on getting the user signed in.
From here it's the fun stuff.
We get to now add achievements.
We get to add leaderboards.
We can share our game, play with
a friend, that kind of stuff,
now that we've gone through
all the hard work of getting
the user signed in.
Let's start having some fun.
And we're going to do
that in the next chapter.
So I'll see you in a few days.
Thanks.